for a very long time now humans have had
a love affair with fountains it could be
a nice gurgle in a park that spices up a
picnic a seal
vomiting water through all eternity to
amuse tourists for a young boy who made
his dad pull over because he really
really has to go over and over again
whatever people just enjoy being near
water that does stop but no one enjoys a
fountain more than this man mark fuller
the CEO and co-founder of wet design for
he is the creator of this this and for
just two hundred million or so dollars
this I recently visited wets
headquarters in Burbank California
partly to find out how mark turned
fountains into hi-tech performance art
but mostly so that I could do this
[Music]
if you've ever run across a 300 foot
stream of dancing water or a sidewalk
that spits out fire there's a good
chance that the people at wet made it
the company has pursued this very unique
line of work since 1983 that has done
hundreds of projects all over the world
although it's perhaps best known for the
Bellagio fountain
almost every piece of the fountains the
lights the water nozzles the audio gear
gets designed and manufactured here and
much of it is the brainchild of Mark
which brings us to an obvious question
how and why does one become a fountain
man I've never really had a major
surgery but I have to tell him I'm a
little bit afraid that if they ever take
the scalpel what comes out may be clear
and red marks enthusiasm for playful
spectacles came to him as a young boy
while on that most American of
adventures a visit to Disneyland I was 9
and we made our first trip to Disneyland
a we left from Salt Lake City then was
like a 16 hour drive to Los Angeles and
I just fell in love with what Walt
Disney had created and I thought man if
you can't be God Walt's got a pretty
close second here and I set myself a
goal of working for Disney when I grew
up and then you actually end up becoming
and imagine their idea when I graduated
from Stanford I went to work right for
Disney and there could have been no more
perfect you know postgraduate experience
than going from Stanford to Disney and I
learned so much there and you're at
Disney for a while and then you and a
couple of partners decide to break off
and start wet and that's when he got a
call from Steve Wynn the Las Vegas real
estate tycoon as he says here's the
goals I want people to not think they're
in Las Vegas I want them to be
completely in a separate space and he
said we need to tie this you know to
really beautiful music there's a third
condition I think oh my gosh what says
he says this has to be the biggest thing
you'll ever do in your life Terry
thought we kept that for a while I think
we've gone a little beyond that but it
was Steve really put us on the map
Steven Spielberg once described the
Bellagio fountains as the greatest
single piece of public entertainment on
planet Earth and even though they've
been around for decades they remain
iconic amusing locals tourists and movie
goers alike
but what really fascinated me about what
story is how the fountains are made the
engineering and material science
pushed the limits of what's possible and
it's hard water in a tube wants to be
this chaotic sloshing around thing and
what you found a way to do was to to
tame it and send it in one Direction's
technique called laminar flow what's
like the kids or laminar flow well if
you think of water molecules like a
bunch of people kind of running around
and somebody says get out of here and
they all cram towards the door that's
like water coming out of your faucet or
your garden hose but if you've mentioned
a military parade where everybody laughs
laughs laughs right laughs no marching
in parallel step then everybody exits
the door if it's six people wide in the
theater it's six people wide through the
nozzle the door six people wide down the
street so you get those water molecules
all marching at the same speed in the
same direction but it's not unlike
coherent light in the laser beam
presence you guys do everything from the
you know the architecture all the way up
to building how does this process work
sometimes a client will come and say we
just saw the Bellagio or something
you've done they engage us for what we
call a concept design phase and work and
we'll come up with several ideas that
we're excited about from that we do the
basic architecture surrounding it and
then we'll do the engineering for the
fountain part I've no interest in making
stuff that somebody else does that's
part of doing something new we have a
new device then of course we design to
make that this means inventing things
like this dragon light contraption that
helped make the dubai fountain stand
this is our biggest underwater light
they're unbelievably bright for this
fountain that's on fire fire and water
it's borderline insane to make so much
hardware but mark has embraced the
madness how many square feet is your
whole facility you know I should know
that I'm gonna say it's around two
hundred thousand give or take of that
their workshops are huge super clean and
whimsical with a giant robot hidden
doors that lead to Marc's personal
office this is my hangout hideaway the
glorious wood shop and even a gym with
Eric the trainer this guy does push-ups
like the Jack LaLanne of today there's
also a lot of hard tech that goes into
the fountain from advancements in
chemistry to new kinds of optics
sometimes you have to dig down one level
beneath the engineering to the actual
science we have for science labs here we
have scanning electron microscopes high
pressure gas chromatographs mass
spectrometers all sorts of things to
really analyze materials and how they'll
interact with each other and with water
and soap all of this technology
eventually comes together at the final
assembly which was designed by Gary
officially this is called the bright
room but this is where we house our
surface mount assembly equipment and
then the final assembly and test of the
lights okay so our customers constantly
come to us and just say hey do something
easy just do something you haven't done
before
and do it away it's never been done yeah
so that's what we're constantly push
ourselves this most recent thing that
we're working on is 20,000 lights over
2,100 shooters 300 robotic devices and
several million gallons in the basin
having the top itself every time out
makes life tough own way and so do the
boom-and-bust cycles of the business it
seems like to me it's just hard to keep
getting bigger yeah you know I read once
every every great offer goes to bed at
night wondering if you'll ever wake up
with a new story I did go to Paris I'm
thinking you know well we have a new
idea tomorrow and so far we they keep
coming there's something in water that
really draws you and I were like 7 th
percent of it right we're born out of
water coming out of our mother's womb
it's such a fantastic substance now we
are doing a few exciting things for the
future which are so big so great for
consumers well yeah to democratize what
we're doing everybody doesn't have some
big pile of money to do a public feature
but why shouldn't you be able to do that
at home why shouldn't you be able to to
be the coolest family you know we're all
the PTA families want to come and have
the party you know in the summer party
of your house cuz you've got this great
a Bellagio fountain in my backyard to
impress the Joneses yes please just so
long as there's plenty of fire thanks
for watching if you want to see more
hello world click on the link to
subscribe